how did your music look during the
the first few years of your being in
college before your brother shows up
our music during that time was terrible
because when we were in the park we were
mostly doing covers of other people but
when
i was in college we experimented with a
lot of different genres so that's music
that is
never gonna see the light of day we have
all of that in our you know on our hard
drives but
we would spend you know six months
working on song that was music that
sounded very musical theater
and then we would spend six months
working on music that was very hip-hop
focused and ryan my middle brother
rapped on a couple of songs and those
will
definitely never come out um but then we
did some songs that were more like
simon and garfunkel folk and it took all
of that time over those four years
to say okay we want to bring a little
bit of this genre in a little bit of
this genre a little bit of this genre
until we actually found our sound and
that's one of the things when when
other newer artists are asking us for
advice we say
take the time to explore what you want
your sound to be
because if you write a song and then put
out your first song if that's
not what you want to be you're you're
throwing something out there that you've
now established yourself this is the
sound that you have
so take some time to really figure out
who you want to be
as an artist and that's what we did when
i was in college so i would go home
and we would play and we would write and
we would record things and like i said
most of it is terrible and most of it's
going to be terrible in the beginning
because you're just learning how to do
it but
we took that time to figure out okay
this is what ajr sound is this is what
we want to communicate with our lyrics
and then when we started putting stuff
out for real then we had a concrete idea
of okay this is the path we want to go
down
so how many hours a week would you go
play or make music with your
brothers when you were in college maybe
10 to 12 hours a week
um i would go home and i would always
you know combine it with bringing
laundry home for my parents to do my
laundry when i would
you know go do that or make them make me
dinner or something like that
so then my next question is about your
brother applying to college because he
ends up getting into colombia
it sounds like as during your final
semester at columbia and his first
semester at columbia
and then your younger brothers in high
school that you make your first hit
and it probably takes a bit of time for
it to become a hit but you know what is
the process you write this song
and then how does it get out into the
world and what happens next
so we wrote this song in the fall of
2012
and this was the the either the end of
the
our career or the beginning of our
career and i'll explain what i mean by
that
we decided that we had written so many
songs and we had you know
tested them out on youtube and
soundcloud and and places like that
and we decided okay if this one doesn't
do anything
then we're just gonna pause we're really
just gonna focus on school and get a
real job
what sorry wow this is very very high
stakes here adam
um but well before we see we before we
we get to that
um you know there's this idea i think is
malcolm gladwell about how
if you spend like 10 000 hours doing
something you become like really really
expert
it sounds like at this point you've
probably put in about that many hours if
you add up like all the times performing
in washington square park and then all
the time
um is that fair to say i mean your
younger brothers
it seems like they started out very
young as well um you guys must be like
incredibly veteran
um musicians and performers at this
point do you believe in the ten thousand
hour
principle or something like it i do
believe in the ten thousand hour
principle but i believe in it for every
bit of it
meaning if you're a writer and you're
writing your own music you need to put
ten thousand ten thousand hours into
writing
if you're just gonna play you need to
put ten thousand hours into playing
if you wanna you know figure out the
branding and marketing and the messaging
of something you need to put 10
000 hours into that so the music
industry
and i'm sure we can talk about this more
but is so much more than just
making a song and putting it out there
are so many other pieces that go into it
but yeah i'm a big believer in paying
your dues and putting in your time
okay so back to 2012 you have this uh
hit song and you're like okay guys if
this thing doesn't work out maybe we
should
go become management consultants or
something
i mean i made that up but um so so what
is the process through which this
music gets out in the world so
it all happened during a psychology
class at columbia
so i'm sitting paying attention taking
notes and ryan is sitting next to me
on twitter and he's taking the link on
youtube of this this song i'm ready that
we put out
and he's tweeting it out to you know 100
different celebrities from miley cyrus
to justin bieber
and the very last one we did where he
did was sia
and sia was the only one who responded
and said
i love this she retweeted it and she
said come downtown and meet me at my
hotel
i want to meet you guys and we thought
we thought she was catfishing us we
thought it was like a fake account this
was before the point when she was
wearing the
the um you know the bag over her head
before she had the wig
so we went down to her hotel and she
walks literally out of her hotel singing
our song and said
okay let's go to brunch and we went to
brunch with sia and that was kind of the
the very beginning of it she introduced
us to people in the industry
we met with a few labels i love sia so
much now
this is the greatest story of all time
she's she's amazing because not only is
she an amazing artist
she's an amazing writer and she can get
in the mindset of so many different
artists and write songs based on their
perspective and that's one of the things
that we really appreciated about her
this seems like a movie plot this seems
like uh you know like
the end of a disney movie um you know
where
sia comes out and connects to people
okay so so let's go through some of the
next things where
so then sia introduces you to people
that are label
yeah people at her label people at other
labels and we have a whole bunch of
label meetings
and every single one of them said you
know
this song is good but we're going to put
you in the room with really big writers
like max martin and dr luke
and they're going to write all your
songs for you and then you'll put them
out and we said
no we're we're definitely uninterested
in that and then we met
our manager who she also introduced us
to
and his name is steve greenberg and he
said
i really like what you have cause it
doesn't sound like anything else on the
radio
and he said it was it was something that
was unique because we made the entire
record
in that dorm room we in our mix between
our parents living room and that dorm
room
it didn't sound professional it didn't
sound like it was made in a recording
studio
and he said that's what made it stand
out and so
we ended up staying independent and not
doing a record deal
we did a deal with him and started our
own company called ajr productions
that sounds like such a risk man like i
feel like any artist and you show up and
they're like
okay we're gonna do this thing and
here's some producers and here's some
writers and we can work with this
and then you were like no
that seems incredibly ballsy
it was so risky and basically it was
choosing between do we believe in
ourselves and the vision that we have
for this
or do we want to take the big check
right now but have to completely change
everything about us
there's something really important about
that story adam um because i feel like
the vast majority of humans in that
situation would have been like well
these are professionals they know better
than us
like that you know like they know how to
make hits they've got a bunch of
platinum records on the wall we don't
have [ __ ] like that
like you know like like let's get in
there and like see what we can do
together like that
like what percentage of artists do you
think would have had that attitude i
feel like
you know 85 would have gone that
direction
i think um were you getting advice from
other people during this time i guess
your parents were like you do you
or like but like was there were there
musicians we didn't know anybody
the only person we knew that was like
actually in the music industry
was sia at that point and we'd known her
for like a week
so we didn't have anybody giving us
advice and we just said look
you know we've taken skills that we've
gotten from
learning music but then we've also taken
skills from i studied business at
columbia so i was like
okay let me think through this from a
business perspective do we want to give
up
all our rights to everything for this
check that could end up being really
small in the long run
or do we want to try because sia really
liked the song let's see if other people
really like the song like
radio stations and it ended up paying
off
oh wait okay so you turned down this
this label deal but you hook up with
sia's manager
um sia introduced us to our current
manager it wasn't her manager
but it was this guy she knew and her
manager knew because he
did hansen and he did the jonas brothers
there there is something about like the
the three brothers uh
band i mean i can't believe he did
hansen and the jonas brothers holy [ __ ]
he like specializes in like freaking
brother bands i wonder if he
he just does brother bands he'd be like
if there aren't three brothers i'm not
interested
no the other the songs that you that you
would know that he uh he
did who let the dogs out and it's
actually his voice on the record that's
the dog barking
um he did stacy's mom stacy's mom a huge
you know hit he's done a lot of those
weird songs
so he becomes your manager and then
you're like we're gonna go off on our
own so then what
then our manager sits down and plays
our song called i'm ready for a guy
named kid kelly and kid kelly
was the you know head of sirius xm hits
one which is
the biggest pop station in the country
on on satellite radio
and he fell in love with it and so
immediately he started playing the song
even before the song officially came out
on itunes which was
crazy then when the song came out on
itunes and this was
pre-streaming being the majority of what
happens in the music industry
he started playing the song on siriusxm
and it just exploded
[Music]
you